cuál fue la traslación aplicada para
mover la figura continua azul a la
figura punteada anaranjada aquí tenemos
la figura azul la figura continua azul y
se movió a esta de acá la forma en la
cual a mí me gusta pensar en estas
traslación es es pensar que le tuvo que
haber pasado alguno de los puntos por
ejemplo a este de aquí o sea si está
aquí y se movió para acá que le sucedió
pues se movió dos unidades hacia la
izquierda
- dos en la coordenada x y una dos tres
unidades hacia arriba o sea tres en la
coordenada y entonces aquí en la primera
coordenada se recorrió dos hacia la
izquierda tendríamos que poner menos dos
si fuera hacia la derecha tendríamos que
poner dos y se movió tres unidades hacia
arriba aquí sería 3
muy bien